13 years of waiting is finally over
former military leader Musa dadis Kamara
finally faces trial
he and 10 others are the alleged
masterminds of a massacre
they will come face to face with
survivors and the families of hundreds
of civilians who were murdered tortured
or raped by Security Forces
it's too early to say if the outcome
will be what we expect but for now we're
giving a court the benefit of the doubt
the government has promised to safeguard
the Integrity of the process and
guarantee protection for Witnesses
the proceedings are being watched
closely by International institutions
like the United Nations today reversing
a culture of impunity into a culture of
Justice
activists say the trial is an important
step but will also be a difficult one
frankly there are a lot of concerns this
trial is unfolding in a complicated
moment for guinea there is a hunter
government in power and there have been
rights abuses escalating a ban on the
opposition a ban on public protest
during this time unisunta is under
interest pressure and making a political
Capital out of this trial by the next
few weeks and months will determine
whether the process is politically
motivated or I genuinely attempt to find
Justice for victims and members of their
families
the international criminal court says
it's watching the trial closely
we bow not to the judge we bow to
Justice it's something above us we have
to bow to Justice and respect justice
otherwise it's the the law of the gun
and the bullet and the bully
the victims come to court in search of
closure but it's not certain if all who
come will find the answers they've been
looking for and whether the trials
outcome will help this nation heal
Ahmed Idris Al jaze